he waited more than 12 hours before
appearing to react to an invasion he had
predicted and one which he could not
stop good afternoon
the russian military has begun a brutal
assault on the people of ukraine
without provocation without
justification
without necessity
this is a pre-meditated attack
putin is the aggressor
putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences the sanctions a tool of
deterrence that so clearly failed now
must become a tool of punishment cut off
russia's largest bank a bank that holds
more than one third of russia's banking
assets by itself
cut it off from the u.s financial system
and today we're also blocking four more
major banks
that means every asset they have in
america will be frozen
the subtext here was clear the invasion
has happened it couldn't be stopped it
can't be stopped now is about cutting
russia off putin's aggression against
ukraine will end up costing russia
dearly
economically and strategically
we will make sure of that
putin will be a pariah on the
international stage
sanctions are the only weapon the west
is prepared now to use against nuclear
russia and one of the threats from a man
who western leaders once thought they
could manage and could read a statement
that he gave last night will that the
what the threat that he gave the west
will face consequences greater than any
you have faced in history is he
threatening a nuclear strike
i have no idea
what he's threatening i know what he has
done
the president announced more u.s troops
will move through europe here to nato's
eastern flank and yet more will be sent
from america a united front against an
autocrat they want to isolate
the president has spent much of the day
in here in the west wing shuttling
between the oval office and the
situation room and honestly the gravity
of the moment he now faces cannot be
overstated the leader of the free world
forced to contemplate that great fear
for so long a confrontation with russia
it is why he said again as he has so
many times before america will not fight
in ukraine
if the president's age has been cited as
a problem well for this moment it gives
him a vital perspective of history
but it doesn't give him the answers such
is this challenge to world order to
peace
mark stone sky news at the white house